this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular celebrities pop in to have a
drink
sometimes they share stories and even
secrets because as we all know what the
bartender ears is confidential isn't it
so I'm sitting there telling Bob we're
in walks one of my favorite customers
ever law Croft now I don't need to tell
you why she's monthly because mine every
time she comes in my mushroom gets
hotter than the most levels on Super
Mario Brothers but I digress so she
comes in and I notice she she looks a
little different and I asked our sim is
Crofton did she do something different
to your hair she says no no but there's
definitely something different so what
is it ah I can't put my finger on it
she says she called a breast reduction
well like that you get a pin drop in the
bar because it became so quiet the only
thing I could hear as a collective gasp
but man just go huh you see when law
enters the room everybody listens and
often does other things but I won't go
into that so the idea of her getting a
breast reduction was just shocking and
I'll said mrs. Croft what what convinced
you to do such a thing she said well I
never wanted it anyway in fact the whole
idea the whole getup and everything it
wasn't my idea I'll say all you mean
she's as well it all started when I was
just lonely archaeologist and I did not
look like how I do now I had glasses but
teeth bad hand whole package so she told
me that she wears in the paper that they
were looking for female archaeologists
for this game called Tomb Raider the
only thing is she had to be strong
shared to know martial arts and she had
to know weapons well luckily her father
used to go hunting with Dick Cheney so
she knew all that stuff so she showed up
she was more qualified than most of the
other women there but they said that she
need to be improved
so while you made approved they said
well it adds so what do you mean
enhanced they said we're gonna make you
more anatomically incorrect than a
Barbie doll she goes oh ok I got it
so they give a makeover the given of the
glasses give us some dental work
well obviously the game was a big hit
and they want her to do more but with
that came a certain sacrifice
you see they told her that with every
game of breasts had to get bigger and in
between the first and second game
actually made them so big that in one
level they served as a flotation device
in the river by the time they were done
in look tie she was hiding to
Hindenburg's I mean they were just
gigantic
she said kids were jumping on them like
they were trampolines they used to joke
that some of the warp zones for Super
Mario 3 were stuck in her cleavage in
fact a lot of things Morgan stuck in her
cleavage
they found Donkey Kong jr. earthworm jim
Alucard from Castlevania 3 so she said
enough is enough but people start
disappearing in my breasts I think
they're too big so she decided to have
them reduced the only downside is the
first time she did they deflated my
pills before people kept getting lost in
and now people start tripping over so
she finally said all right all right
just get him to a large size but just
not too large and so by the last game
she was here they were finally a decent
size but now she got him even smaller I
mean she practically look flat-chested
and so of course I had a scar said like
what made you want to make them even
smaller than I mean they were a decent
size by the last game
she's will found out about this code in
one of the games well you could actually
play me naked and she said even though
she found out about it much later that
was the final straw for she just
couldn't stand to be a sex object and
nothing else and then Samus from the
other table came over and said oh I know
probably similar to that you want me to
track him down
you want to track down the guy who did
that and I told about you you don't want
to deal with that
and then she brought up a point to me I
never thought about before she said you
know you never realized that the smaller
and smaller my breasts get in the game
the less successful the games are I mean
the games just aren't as good as the
first one like every single time my
fresh string people just don't pay as
much attention to the gameplay or how to
make it a better game and I'll so no
that's ridiculous I'm sure it's just a
long stroke of bad luck but there didn't
really help ere we open the paper it's
all there's an advertisement for Tomb
Raider starring Laura cross breaths
jostle breaths nothing else it's just a
giant rag going around shooting things
and trying to suffocate them by putting
them in her cleavage well lower looked
very destroyed by that I mean absolutely
distraught by the whole thing she then
called Samus back and said boy what
could you do anyway
and salmon said Laura this could be the
beginning of a beautiful friendship you
see all strange things as a vault under
seal all streams things in the pixel
Palace so I'll see a lot of strange
things as a bartender at the pixel
Palace and that ain't no lie